how's the charisma he made it to part 2
night 2 it seems to be following the
same pattern with a few differences so
far so we'll see we'll see how far it
goes maybe it adds some more stuff to
the progression of the depression I just
said that cause Ryan I don't even know
that's listen to this guy talk for 5
minutes hey buddy mr. Bain hey man I
missed you man I miss ya he's so cute I
love your eyebrows they needed a little
bit of plucking though let's just make
sure we have this music bags shut up you
don't know that would I want to holding
the cupcake it's like the cutest thing
I've seen a man laughs except you of
course Bay you're my BAE you're my BAE
you're my BAE I think that's the point
of this game just convincing shut up
shut your damn mouth you how long I mean
to convince them that you're there BAE
Jesus Freddie you gained weight you look
fat as [ __ ] Oh
what wait a cup yeah well I go where I
come from where do you can't Fred hey I
got he's good
there you are buddy wait how did he get
there
damn it Oh what are you steep stay what
is it steep I'm blinking you Steve stop
this nonsense okay Steve Steve damn it
Steve I have to do the the bags actually
to beg Steve
no guys hey buddy I'm just gonna sit
here wait for you to suck mud nothing
don't kill me please I'm Swedish and we
can't die
oh wait that to see I mean all right all
right [ __ ] me then Freddie what do you
Freddie this is really awkward I don't
know I don't know what to tell you man
Jesus Christ this [ __ ] music box
thing and suck my dick Freddie I don't
know what to tell you man don't don't
just kill me all right
it's so much [ __ ] going on what am I
supposed to do
Freddie [ __ ] off all right jesus [ __ ]
hell man no you were here now you're
both here like what the [ __ ] do you want
from me dammit dammit it's 3:00 in the
morning
go to bed go to bed and dream about
Jesus Jesus guys like what do they want
from me
mm laughs get off they were so fun wait
you're Jeff Lahti tea held a high ne
suis camo never go to cloak I told
spinner I have lots PLA also call me
sickling up forever anymore a friend to
that he'll victor abla boys care of
I know there you are I missed you BAE I
love your eyelashes I think they're very
pretty and I think you're very pretty
and I would look at you all day if the
game would let me but it doesn't so I
love that little thing up there it's
[ __ ] weird man it's with the audio
shut up Jesus anyway come on baby light
my fire suck my dick come on baby like
right shut stop saying hi alright I
don't give a shape still there huh oh
you're there buddy well are you gonna
Hank are you gonna come out are you
gonna hang what do you want from me huh
damn it Steve go to bed Steve no one
likes you anyway
Steve Steve damn it Steve what the [ __ ]
are you the ghost of Steve I don't know
what to tell you oh [ __ ] [ __ ] me man
what am I supposed to do there's so much
[ __ ] going on I can't even beat date
Steve I'm getting damn it what are you
what is it
well I'm [ __ ] in the ass now hey you
didn't see me there buddy hey just a
clown oh shut up why does it say
balloons [ __ ] off all right
this isn't mean I'm dead I can use the
flashlight that means I'm jump-scare
[ __ ] off will ya God am I just waiting
to get [ __ ] there we go alright well
then thank you I suck at this game but I
have to play it cuz everyone won't shut
up about it like that
think that's summarize it pretty well
he's my baby I just can't sleep
bum bum bum when can them to look at me
my ass becomes a sheep what's with that
[ __ ] sound does that mean Stevie's
here or I'd see a great [ __ ] I hear them
in event yes [ __ ] hey buddy so now I
put on the mask or or what's going on
like it huh I we're safe okay so that
Steve [ __ ] the [ __ ] off go away I got
better things to do in my laugh like
wind up music boxes that's what I don't
that's why I mean it's not even 3 a.m.
son of a [ __ ] say oh come on you're
still there buddy I don't know what to
tell you man there's so much going on
like I can there's no way I can keep
track of both of them
it's the up [ __ ] me Steven Steve is
about to [ __ ] me save [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
you shall not [ __ ]
alright damn it hey buddy how you doing
man hey dude man
that's great I love you I love you so
much
ooh baby I love you sway every day again
I wouldn't let any everyday what are you
doing here you're not even a man Adam
shut up shut your [ __ ] mouth all
right
you don't talk to your senpai like that
what are you huh what are you who made
you and why huh
you tell me [ __ ] all right [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off you and your pantyhose
you [ __ ] pendejo your hunt though
I'll give you that [ __ ] um [ __ ] I she's
gone well now oh you piece of [ __ ] oh
you know can't you tell I'm Freddy hey
guys I'm Freddy what's up what's up I'm
Freddy
hey what's up I'm Freddy Freddy Wong
here no Freddy Kreuger navigate Freddy
[ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know
oh he's gone he's gone to [ __ ] now I'm
dead now I'm dead [ __ ] off die stadt die
start
what do you want from me damn it [ __ ]
music boxing's you're there and Freddy's
for [ __ ] [ __ ] and damn it I hate
the music box it's pissing me off
oh god all right all right all right I
get it no all right what do you want
from me
come on we're almost there I do they
know like what what's going on anybody
ahh I thought we were friends
oh now I'm dead no it's yeah so I don't
want your balloons go home to Sweden
[ __ ] off all right
again all right what [ __ ] me then come
on I'm ready
[ __ ] me [ __ ] off me
that's so scary I don't like his face I
don't like his attitude I don't like his
name I don't know what his name is but I
bet if I knew it I would have liked it
I don't like he's cool swag it's not a
word this kids still use that word like
my hair it's so fluffy today huh isn't
this great
we got a little bit of fluffiness going
out you don't like fluff well you can
you say you like the skin then how
[ __ ] dare you say you like this game
if you don't like fluff how [ __ ] dare
all of you I dare all of you to suck my
fluff come I come I come I come I come
it's so bad at this
[ __ ] off Steve [ __ ] off go back to Hell
where you came from go back into the
womb of Justin Bieber you paints the
shape well we're halfway there I'm
making a sweat
[ __ ] why I why not Freddy what are you
doing here Freddy look Freddy we're
friends right
Freddie you don't like it Freddie
Freddie she don't like it you can just
go home all right you don't like it
we're brothers named Anne brother
damnit I hear them into vents alright
the [ __ ] is there I don't get it
Freddie
if you don't want to be friends with me
then why why do you have to make out
with me every night after dark and now
tell anyone about it
I wrote you on Facebook and you just
ignored me do you understand how that
makes me feel like Freddie do you
understand what a piece of [ __ ] you are
no look Freddie I'm just like you come
back I might come back come back come
with me yeah lick my ass senpai lick
[ __ ] off this flashlight I don't know
how much I'm supposed to do with it oh
you're here now that's this [ __ ]
great house oh great great
come on alright I'm dead I get it funny
phonetic Luka nolanda
[Music]
all right if this video gets 80,000
likes i'll upload part 3 you both let me
know if you want more uh I kind of enjoy
it
I'm not gonna lie I like the challenge
but yeah that's it for me for now see
you the next one as always stay awesome
Oh